how far would you go to protect your
business from crooks one business owner
showing no fear as two would-be crooks
walk right in the door thank you for
joining us at six i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm denise valdez in a very calm
matter-of-fact way the smoke shop owner
took matters into his own hands after he
says two people tried to steal from a
store victoria saha joins us live from
smoke storm near sahara and arville with
how the situation unfolded
yeah the owner of smokestream said that
he noticed one person holding this door
wide open then two people wearing ski
masks walked in that's when he says he
knew there was trouble
it was mid afternoon on wednesday when
owner johnny newen was working at his
smoke shop surveillance video shows two
people walking up to the counter ski
masks caught new one's attention you
hear him asking why they are wearing the
masks why are you just wearing masks
like that around this moment you see
newman reaching for something near the
register one person tries running off
with a tip jar another jumps over the
counter this is when the owner attacks i
had to assume they had a firearm
so i just want to make sure that
i could protect myself i didn't have any
thoughts in the moment it was just a lot
of adrenaline going through my body
and it was kind of like a
fight-or-flight response
like even
even thinking about it now my heart rate
is like a little bit elevating after the
stabbing you see newin dragging the
person to the front of the store he says
he then called police and paramedics
according to metro the two seen in this
video are teen boys new and says that he
did stab the young men seven times his
condition is unknown but newman says he
was talking when help showed up as for
new and he says he will be buzzing
customers in from now on and he will be
arming himself victoria saha live local
now
the store owner in this situation stayed
remarkably calm from beginning to end
but if you find yourself in a robbery
the department of public safety says you
should stay calm and do not resist
follow the robbers directions but do not
offer more than what they ask for make
mental notes of the robber's appearance
after it's over go to a safe location
and call police